I usually for the Mishmars we've usually been
doing things in Shabbos, but because this Mishmar
was a Shavuos Mishmar, and it was supposed
to connect with the Chabura, so I figured
I would speak about the Masechta that we're
learning, Maseches Beitzah and Shavuos. And we'll have
to do a little bit with Shabbos also,
but I didn't have time to connect everything
together in terms of Shabbos. So I figured
I would just speak about an interesting topic
that comes up at the beginning of Maseches
Beitzah that the entire Jewish world is constantly
curious about. But we'll start in Hilchos Shavuos.
The Shiur will be a little, usually it's
a lot more Halakhic oriented, this may also
be a little more Lomdus oriented, but I
think it's an interesting discussion, interesting topic, interesting
thought. So the Magen Avraham opens up Siman
Taf Tzadik Daled and tells us that on
the first night of Shavuos, one has to
wait to make Kiddush until Tzeis Hakochavim, because
you need Temimos, the Pasuk tells us Sheva
Shabbatos Temimos, you need seven full weeks of
Sefiras HaOmer, seven full weeks have to be
completed until the end of the last day.
So you have to wait until the day
is completely done before you make Kiddush at
Tzeis Hakochavim. That's what the Magen Avraham tells
us at the very beginning of Siman Taf
Tzadik Daled. The Pri Megadim and the Mishna
Berurah there in Sif Katan Alef points out
that just like the Magen Avraham says that
this applies to Kiddush, so too the Taz
in Sif Katan Alef says it applies to
Tefillah, and also you should wait to daven
Maariv until Tzeis Hakochavim. That's what the Pri
Megadim points out. Then the Pri Megadim continues
and at the end he comments and he
says that the Knesses HaGedolah, the Knesses HaGedolah
was one of the 17th century Turkish Achronim,
he's one of the great he was a
commentary on the Tur. So in the Knesses
HaGedolah that the Pri Megadim quotes, he writes
that not only is this true that you
should wait to make Kiddush, you should wait
for davenning until Tzeis Hakochavim on the first
night of Shavuos, but it is also true
that you should wait to make Kiddush and
wait for davenning on the second night of
Shavuos. That's what the Knesses HaGedolah says. The
Pri Megadim disagrees with the Knesses HaGedolah when
he quotes him and the Pri Megadim says
it doesn't make sense. The whole reason why
we wait until Tzeis Hakochavim is because we
need Sheva Shabbatos Temimos. We need seven complete
weeks. Once the first day of Shavuos hit,
so you have seven complete weeks. Who cares,
the Knesses HaGedolah, who cares whether it's the
second day is a Safeika DeYoma, but you
already had the seven complete weeks. So it
just doesn't make sense why you would need
a wait on the second day even though
you would need a wait on the first
night. This is what the Knesses HaGedolah says,
this is what the Pri Megadim says. That's
Machlokes between them. So the Pri Megadim is
a lot more convincing. Yeah. Go back to
a shiur you gave a few weeks ago.
Did the Knesses HaGedolah count every night, tonight
are one or two? So the Baal HaMaor
question at the end of Pesachim. Yeah, the
Baal HaMaor asks whether he should do both.
So l'chora he did. But yet he still
said again the Safeika DeYoma of Shavuos tells
you that the second day should be like
the first day for some reason. But again
this is a question. So the first night,
the chidush is we usually have a thing
called Tosefes, Tosefes Shabbos, Tosefes Yom Tov. As
we pointed out in the past, Rov HaRishonim
explain that Tosefes Shabbos is DeOraisa. The Rambam,
but Rov say that. So it's a real
thing, and yet on Shavuos because the Pasuk
says Temimos we don't have Tosefes of Yom
Tov. Says the Knesses HaGedolah we even don't
have Tosefes Yom Tov on the second night.
But the Pri Megadim says no you can
start you can start early on the second
night of Shavuos. Pri Megadim is Meikel. Yes.
So Pri Megadim is also much more convincing.
We understand you need Sheva Shabbatos Temimos Tiheyena,
but how should that impact the second night
at all? So different ways to answer that
question. One Rav Schachter has in a Teshuvah
that he wrote during Covid on this topic,
so he points out that the Netziv, the
Binyan Shlomo also has it, Rav Shlomo MiVilna,
but the Netziv has in the HaEmek Davar
in Parshas Emor that the Pasuk tells us
Ukrasem Be'etzem HaYom Hazeh Mikra Kodesh Yihiyeh Lachem,
I think it's something along those lines in
Perek Kaf Gimmel in Parshas Emor. So the
fact that it says Ukrasem Be'etzem HaYom Hazeh,
that is coming Lemiyutei, Be'etzem means in the
middle of the day, that's Lemiyutei that comes
to exclude the night before, or the day
before. Meaning this is telling you that even
though there's generally a rule, a Mitzvah called
Tosefes Shabbos, Tosefes Yom Tov, Shavuos has a
Gezeras Hakasuv that tells you Be'etzem HaYom Hazeh,
that no, Shavuos starts at the day or
when Tzeis Hakochavim hits, but you can't start
beforehand. That's the Drasha that the Netziv has.
So if that's true, what the Knesses HaGedolah
would say is that it's not about Temimos,
it's not about this idea that we need
completeness. No, the idea is that Shavuos is
unique in that You need be'etzem hayom hazeh,
you need it to start on the day.
So the idea of two days of Yom
Tov, as we'll see bli neder be'ezras Hashem
soon, in our perek he spoke about during
the week with the korbanos of Shavuos, with
the eating the dairy the night before? No,
no, no, no, no. Yeah, no, yeah. Is
this all this is is that what it's
talking about? No, this is You mean something
else you mentioned earlier in the week about
Shavuos being unique and that, you know, the
Yom Tov started by the day and not...
Yeah, so that's not Shavuos. Rav Schachter writes
this in Ginas Egoz that the idea of
simchas Yom Tov is depend is like kodashim
in that the day follows the night? Yeah,
exactly. That's why the Steipler and others would
do such a thing. No, but this is
that meaning be'etzem doesn't mean the day. It
also means the night, but it means when
the day starts which is at night. So
if that's true, the Knesset HaGedolah would say,
you're going to tell me it's all about
temimos. You're right. That only makes sense on
the first night because we only count Sefiras
HaOmer till the first day. But if it's
not about that, it's about that there's something
unique to Shavuos, a gzeiras hakasuv by Shavuos
that excludes tosefes. So what that tells you,
just like the first day you have to
wait, so too the second day because that's
how two days of Yom Tov work. Whatever
you do the first, you do the second.
If it's all about temimos, it just doesn't
make sense on the second day because we
already completed it. But if it's a gzeiras
hakasuv in the Yom Tov of Shavuos, so
once we have Yom Tov sheini shel galuyos,
that's what we would do. That's what The
problem is and Rav Schachter quotes this all
the time. I think he may even have
that in the tshuva. I just didn't get
a chance to look beforehand. He quotes all
the time that he heard from the Chofetz
Chaim. The Chofetz Chaim didn't like when the
Netziv would what he called made up drashos.
We have drashos that Chazal make up, but
nowhere in Chazal does nowhere do we find
in the Gemara that it says be'etzem hayom
hazeh le'miyuta that you can't do tosefes to
exclude tosefes. So it's kind of like a
made-up drasha. So the Chofetz Chaim wasn't so
fond of that. So the question is, is
there another way to understand this Knesset HaGedolah?
And that's what I want to explore. Is
there another way to understand why the Knesset
HaGedolah is machmir to say even on the
second night of Shavuos you should wait until
tzeit hakochavim? That's what Do we hold that
way? We probably a lot of them do
mikveh and vasikin but that's what I want
to explore regardless. Okay, so in general in
terms of the second night of Yom Tov
outside of Shavuos, on Pesach, on Succos. So
is there an allowance, do we do tosefes
on the second night? Do we take on
Yom Tov early on that second night on
a typical Yom Tov? I'm not talking about
Shabbos when Shabbos is the second night, but
on a typical Yom Tov. You have Succos
on a Monday and Tuesday. So on Monday
night, Tuesday night. So on Tuesday night can
I take in Succos at 4:30? after plag,
whenever plag is. Am I allowed to do
that? So the Maharil is quoted, the achronim
all quote this Maharil and they say their
tefilla. So he writes that the minhag of
the yekkes, the minhag of yotzei Germania, of
the Germans, was that they would not start
the second night of Yom Tov, the leil
beis of a Yom Tov early because of
a chshash. They were worried that what's going
to happen is people they're going to finish
davening, they're going to come home. Everyone's wives
are going to see them they came home
from shul and they're going to start cooking
and preparing the meal. And that's a problem
because you can't cook from one day of
Yom Tov to another day of Yom Tov.
What's that called? Hachana de-Rabbah? Right. That's Hachana
de-Rabbah. You can't cook from one to the
other. Right. That's Gemara in Beitzah. It's almost
the Yom Tov bringing it in for you
for the second day. Okay. So Dave's really
missing out on a lot of a lot
of shiurim. You see. Yeah. So there's a
big discussion. It seems to be hitting the
point that you guys have been doing something.
We've been around picking the right topic. Every
time picking the right topic. So yeah, so
there is a big discussion. It seems to
be a machlokes at the very least in
the achronim but as we pointed out, the
rishonim also about whether what tosefes does is
it changes the day into the next day
or it's just in terms of the issur
melacha. It comes up with Tosafos at the
very beginning of Arvei Pesachim and then many
other places. But that is a big discussion.
But regardless, the question here you're still you're
not allowed to cook from day one to
day two. So until you make Kiddush, it's
probably still day one. So there's still because
even when we take in early, what we'll
say is you can make Kiddush and just
make sure... That's what you mentioned recently with
Sefira. You can still count even though it's
still day of. So that's kind of what
you were... Yeah, yeah, very interesting. Yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah. But this is so but that's
what the Maharil again that was the chshash
that the Maharil had that the minhag of
Germans were they wouldn't take in early on
the second night because they were worried that
then they were going to start preparing too
early. Many places don't are meikel and they
don't worry about such a chshash but that's
what those people did and there are places
that still do that that will wait on
the second night of Yom Tov because we're
worried about that. So for example in our
shul, so we'll daven Maariv before tzeit hakochavim
on a typical second night, but pretty close
to tzeit hakochavim enough that hopefully by the
time you walk back so it'll be about
the time that, you know, your wife lit
candles or something along those lines and then
you can start preparing because if you came
in ten minutes early and the person forgot
and they started setting up his table, so
that's going to be a problem, Hachana de-Rabbah.
That's going to be an issue. So that's
what the Maharil says. says. Then the question
that it begs is whether there is a
din of tosefet by Yom Tov Sheni in
general. Mean is it that you're just allowed
to take it in early, or is there
is there such a din that there's tosefet
Yom Tov on Yom Tov Sheni on the
second day of Yom Tov the second night
of Yom Tov? So what I wanted to
explore just for a little bit is the
concept of Yom Tov Sheni, a concept which
you know caused much controversy in our world.
I remember I was once in Houston, one
of my first years in college. I had
a friend in Houston so I was there
for Yom Tov and I was there as
like so what's the why you think called
Torah Tours? Yes, yes. So I did that
with my me and my friend basically called
Torah Tours and we're like do you have
a friend in Houston can we go? So
it was the three of us and we
did Torah Tours in his shul and I
remember yeah I don't know if I should
say Houston but whatever it was a community.
And I remember walking into shul on the
second day and some guy some older man
comes to me he says Rabbi I have
a question. I was not a rabbi, I
was first year college student. Rabbi I have
a question. And he brings over his friend
he said so his friend starts telling me
that he really wants to make aliyah, really
wants to. So he doesn't keep second day
Yom Tov anymore. And I was like what?
So maybe that's a question for your rabbi,
not for me. People have a hard time
understanding the concept of a second day Yom
Tov. So the concept begins from the Gemara
in Beitzah 4b. The Gemara tells us it
describes how the the way Rosh Chodesh was
originally made, the way that the Beit Din
was mekadesh hachodesh, that they would have the
edim come and then they would tell them
and then Beit Din would basically put out
and tell everyone that it's Rosh Chodesh and
and that's how everything would be. So because
of that obviously caused a lot of issues
because what happened was is if in Beit
Din in Yerushalayim gets the word that today's
Rosh Chodesh, so if you live in America
so you don't know that it's Rosh Chodesh.
So you may not be able to get
till two weeks later. So because of that
once let's say Nisan, Rosh Chodesh Nisan, so
you know it's around the same time so
once a day hits it's either going to
be Tes Vav or Yud Daled. Next day
will be Tes Vav Tes Zayin. So if
you lived in America you weren't sure if
it was today's the fifteenth or tomorrow's the
fifteenth. So they kept two days. Right? Because
again they were able they knew the days
of the month but each month they weren't
sure if it was me'ubar or not. They
weren't sure if it was 29 or 30.
So they knew that either today or tomorrow
was going to be the fifteenth of Nisan
the first day of Pesach but they didn't
know which one. So because of that safek
they were in doubt they had to keep
both days. That's the what we call sfeika
deyoma, that's why there's a second day of
Yom Tov. That's what it is. Originally they
weren't sure, they needed to do both. Again
if you lived in HaMikdash in that area
so obviously you only kept one day because
you knew when Rosh Chodesh was, there was
no reason to ever keep two days. Shoyn.
The the Gemara then tells us: Vehashta and
now, deyadinan bikvia deyarcha, nowadays we know the
calendar. We know what when's the fifteenth of
Nisan we know when's the sixteenth of Nisan.
So if if that's true, mai ta'ama avdinan
trei yomei? Why do we keep two days
Yom Tov then? Doesn't right this is the
question that everyone asks. I know when the
fifteenth of Nisan is why do I have
to keep Yom Tov on the sixteenth of
Nisan? Says says the Gemara: mishum deshalchu mitam
because they sent from Eretz Yisrael, hizharu beminhag
avoteichem biyedeichem, be careful with
the minhag the custom of your forefathers in
your hands, zimnin degazra malchut gezeira because there
may be a time where as Rashi says
that there the kingdom wherever you live the
government will make some sort of shmad and
won't allow you to learn Torah, ve'asi lekal
kulei and it will cause you to forget
the sod ha-ibbur as Rashi says the way
that it calculates and you're going to forget
the whole calendar system and then suddenly you're
stuck and then you're going to have to
keep and then you're going to forget. So
keep two days just so you always keep
two days so you don't run into into
any issues. But but that's what the Gemara
says: hizharu beminhag avoteichem biyedeichem. That's and that's
why we do it. So now if we
have a... but it wasn't a minhag, it
was a safek. Good, we're we're going to
get there. bli neder we're going to get
there. You're making an excellent point. But again
what good you're making an excellent point bli
neder we're going to get there. So so
what comes out though is the second day
of Yom Tov is called sfeika deyoma. It's
based off of a safek. So if we're
talking about the concept of tosefet Yom Tov
obviously there's a safek whether there should be
tosefet Yom Tov right that's the whole point.
Should there be tosefet Yom Tov or not?
That's the safek. So so what should you
do? So in the Klausenberger Rebbe's teshuvos are
called the Divrei Yatziv. So the Divrei Yatziv
in Orach Chayim siman kuf yud zayin he
has a long teshuva about about tosefet. The
Klausenberger was a he was a survivor of
the Holocaust, he was in Auschwitz, he lost
his wife and all his children. Rabbi’s we...
Yes, his Rebbe yes, yes, yes. Yes, yes.
His Rebbe I think Asher Weiss's father is
second day in Auschwitz was he met him.
I think that's what he says. Second day
in Auschwitz he met him. Yeah. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. But so he was a tremendous gadol,
and so in his teshuva called Divrei Yatzev,
so he writes in kuf yud zayin in
Orach Chaim, he has a long thing about
tosefes, but at the very end he discusses
tosefes from Yom Tov to one Yom Tov
to another. And he comments and he says
so because, you know, the whole thing's a
safek, so what you should do is when
you take Tosefet Yom Tov on the first
night, you should have in mind this is
tosefes for both days. That's what he suggests
to do. The problem is that on Shavuos
we don't have tosefes as we pointed out.
As the Magen Avraham tells us, as the
Taz tells us, the Pri Megadim tells us,
we don't do tosefes It's either gezeirat hakatuv
or it's temimos, whatever you want to say,
but there is no tosefes. so you obviously
can't do that. So we have an issue
with that as well. The problem obviously is
that nowadays if we know the keviya deyarcha,
if we know the set calendar, that we
cannot, it should be that we should not
be allowed to take in the second day
of Yom Tov early. Why? Because we know
that the first day is Yom Tov the
second day is chol. We do because minhag
avoteinu beyadeinu. We do because that's the minhag,
that's what we do. But we know the
set calendar. So if we take it in
early, that means we're ending real Yom Tov,
early. We can't do that. So it should
be very very and I think the Divrei
Yatzev he points this out, but it should
be very very difficult to do that. So
you do have an issue. In terms of
Yom Tov sheni and I think we're inching
towards what Arye saying, but there's a it
seems to be machlokes in the rishonim as
to whether Yom Tov sheni is what we
call a minhag or a takana. For example,
I mean there are a lot of examples,
but Tosafos in Sukkah mem dalet amud bet
and the haRosh in Kesuvos in the first
perek in siman hey, both say explicitly that
Yom Tov sheni is called a minhag, what
we would refer to as a custom. On
the other hand, Rashi here in Beitzah dalet
amud bet calls it a, I don't remember
what it's called, a chok kavua, as Rashi
says, shem vadai chok kavua. It's a takana,
that it's a real full-fledged takana. The Ran
in Sukkah also on that Tosafos that I
was talking about, so the Ran also says
it's a takana, the Ramban in Shabbos kaf
gimmel, the haRitzba in Hashan daf yud ches,
they all say it's a takana. They have,
but what's a who cares whether it's a
minhag or takana? So there are a few,
just to name maybe one or two. The
haRosh in Kesuvos that I quoted before discusses
avelus. So avelus, obviously avelus has a source
min hatorah, de'oraita. Right, there's obviously something in
avelus that's de'oraita, but most of avelus is
only derabbanan. So which part of avelus is
de'oraita, you're a for an avelus for, you
didn't. Okay. So what part of avelus is
de'oraita? So this is a big machlokes from
the geonim and the rishonim, what exactly is
de'oraita? Is it the first day, is it
the week, is it less than a day?
A big discussion. So the haRosh there, so
what happens before? What happens if avelus falls,
a person rachmana litzlan has someone niftar on
Yom Tov On Yom Tov? yeah, on Yom
Tov, What's the din? So there's no avelus.
You wait until after Yom Tov. Yom Tov.
cancels shiva, but it doesn't allow for, Yom
Tov sorry cancels shiva, but it also doesn't
allow for avelus to begin yet. So you
would begin afterwards. Now what happens if falls
out on Yom Tov sheni? So that's the
question. So Yom Tov sheni is derabbanan, so
if you have avelus de'oraita, so a de'oraita
is always going to be docheh a derabbanan.
Now the problem is there are many geonim
and the haRosh quotes this, that believe that
avelus yom rishon, meaning the first day of
avelus, shiva definitely not de'oraita. There are many
that believe the first day even the first
day of avelus is not de'oraita, the only
thing that's de'oraita according to some is what
we call aninus. It's the period before you
bury the body when you're an onen, that's
what's de'oraita. So the first day of avelus
happens on Yom Tov sheni, what should you
do? We have avelus derabbanan and we have
Yom Tov derabbanan. So which one wins out?
So says the haRosh, well it's not really
the calculation, the calculation is avelus derabbanan and
the minhag because Yom Tov sheni is only
a minhag. So you would be mitabel, you
would have avelus if it was the first
day of avelus, you would have that even
if it's only derabbanan, you would have it
on Yom Tov sheni because it's a minhag.
So that's a nafka mina of whether it's
a minhag when you have Yom Tov avelus
derabbanan falls out on Yom Tov sheni, do
we keep the avelus or the Yom Tov,
Well it depends if Yom Tov sheni is
a minhag. For burial. The burial you tell
me. I'm saying because I know I can't
remember the thing. Yom Tov sheni legabei met
kechol shavyuhu rabbanan. Rav Chanina Masechet Beitzah here.
And they buried someone in. Yeah, and since
we don't have to worry about bizayon and
everything like they said because it was a
burial. Yeah, yeah, so we wait, we wait
nowadays, you are correct. Yes we did, she
was buried on acharon shel Pesach and my
grandparents my grandmother started avelus on acharon shel
Pesach. Yeah, so again it's
because of this haRosh that if you'll this
is only derabbanan so it's a minhag. But
aninus doesn't start, that's de'oraita. Yeah, correct, but
it doesn't. There would be meaning there would
be no Aninos, there would never be Aninos
in such a case. If a person had,
according to this opinion, if a person had
a Meis die on Yom Tov Sheni of
let's call it Shavuos in the morning and
the burial took place two hours later, there
was never, he was never an Onein. Meaning
he goes and davens in the morning, he
has to say Brachos, all that. So that's
not... another Nafka Mina which is what Tosfos
in Sukkah Mem Daled that I quoted is
talking about is whether you make a Bracha
on Minhagim. This is a big Machlokes in
the Rishonim and then eventually between the Shulchan
Aruch and ha-Rama whether we make a Bracha
on Minhagim. Tosfos there in Sukkah says that
we do make a Bracha, Rabbeinu Tam that
we do make a Bracha on Minhag which
now Ashkenazim pasken, but the Rambam in the
eleventh Perek of Berachos and in the third
Perek of Megillah, there he says no you
don't make a Bracha on Minhagim and that's
how Sephardim pasken. And that's why Hallel Rosh
Chodesh is the classic example. Which means what
though? So now you've got this Minhag of
the second day of Shavuos and you're saying
all these Brachos? No, no, so again we're
trying to figure out what you make a
Bracha on. So this isn't what I'm saying
is in terms of Yom Tov Sheni itself,
it's not clear. The only question would be
in Kiddush. That's the only time you make
a Bracha on the day. You say Mekadesh
Yisrael in this case, Chazarat Hashatz, if you're...
the only thing, well Mekadesh Yisrael, you're saying
Shmoneh Esreh, what Bracha are you making on
the day? You're making a Bracha about the
day, it's Me'ein Hame'ora. It's about the day,
but the Bracha on the day, like for
example, Bracha on Hallel, you're making a Bracha
on the Hallel. So what Bracha do you
make on the... maybe Kiddush. So maybe that's...
but again... but that's on... again they don't
make a Bracha on Hallel. You're saying on
Yom Tov? But that's on Hallel, that's not
on the Yom Tov? Right? That's the difference.
This gets into the things with the burial,
like that says similar over here in Israel
like the day and a half of how
would I not put on Tefillin if you
don't put on Tefillin. Correct. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Same idea, yes, correct. But okay so anyway
so there are Nafka Mina whether it's Minhag
or Takana, whether Yom Tov Sheni is called
that. Again we have a Machlokes, we have
the Rosh who quotes an opinion at least
and Tosfos in Sukkah that clearly say that
it is a Minhag while we have others
that say that it's not a Minhag. We
have Rashi in our Gemara but also the
Ramban, the Ritva, the Ran, they all say
it's really a Takana. The Shitas ha-Rambam is
a little bit confusing. The Rambam writes in
the sixth Perek of Hilchos Yom Tov, Halacha
Yad Daled, I'll just read: Kol ha-dvarim ha-eleh
she'amarnu haynu bizman shehayu Beis Din shel Eretz
Yisrael mekadeshin al pi hare'iyah. Everything that we've
just spoken about talking about Eruv Tavshilin and
pretty much Eruv Tavshilin. But that was only
when they would be mekadesh hachodesh al pi
hare'iyah, meaning the way that they used to
do it based off their sight. Vehayu bnei
hagolah osim shnei yamim kedei le-histalek min hasafek
liphi shelo hayu yodin yom shekidsbu bo bnei
Eretz Yisrael. And so if you lived in
America, you had two days of Yom Tov.
kedei le-histalek min hasafek because you had a
Safek liphi shelo hayu yodin yom shekidsbu bo
bnei Eretz Yisrael because they didn't know when
Eretz Yisrael were mekadesh hachodesh. Aval hayom shebnei
Eretz Yisrael somchin al hacheshbon umekadeshin alav ein
Yom Tov Sheni le-histalek min hasafek ela minhag
bilvad. But nowadays that Bnei Eretz Yisrael they
rely on the calendar and mekadeshin alav and
that's how they're mekadesh it, ein Yom Tov
Sheni le-histalek min hasafek we don't keep Yom
Tov Sheni because we are Safek, ela minhag
bilvad. It's a minhag. That's what it is.
So the Rambam clearly holds Yom Tov Sheni
is a minhag. Right? However, the Rambam in
Kiddush Hachodesh in Perek Hey Halacha Hey writes:
Bizman hazeh she'ein sham Sanhedrin u-Beis Din shel
Eretz Yisrael kovin al cheshbon zeh. Nowadays where
we go based off calendar: Hayah min hadin
sheyihyu be-chol hamakomos osin yom echad bilvad afilu
hamakomos harichokim shebe-chutz la'aretz kemo bnei Eretz Yisrael
she-hakol al cheshbon echad somchin ve-kovin. Really everyone
should keep one day bilvad even if you're
in America, kemo bnei Eretz Yisrael. That would
make sense, keep one day. She-hakol al cheshbon
echad somchin ve-kovin because we're all based off
the calendar anyway. Aval takanas chachamim hu sheyizharu
beminhag avoseihem she-beyadeihem. To be careful what our
forefathers did. So here he calls it a
takanas chachamim. A takana on a minhag? Oh,
so that's clearly something. What exactly does that
mean? I'll give you one more mareh makom
which is the Rambam in Perek Aleph of
Hilchos Yom Tov in Halacha Kaf Beis writes:
Yom Tov Sheni af al pi she-hu mi-divrei
sofrim. Yom Tov Sheni, af al pi she-hu
mi-divrei sofrim even though it is mi-divrei sofrim,
kol davar she-assur ba-rishon assur ba-sheni. Everything that's
assur on the first day is assur on
the second day. Vechol hamechalel Yom Tov Sheni
ve-afilu shel Rosh Hashanah bein bedavar shehu mishum
shevus bein bemelacha etc. Apologize, Halacha Kaf Aleph.
Zeh she-anu osim be-chutz la'aretz kol yom tov
me-elu shnei yamim minhag hu ve-Yom Tov Sheni
mi-divrei sofrim hu u-me-hadvarim she-nis-chadshu ba-galus. Nowadays that
we keep two days of Yom Tov minhag
hu. It's a minhag. Ve-Yom Tov Sheni mi-divrei
sofrim hu. And it's mi-divrei sofrim. And mi-hadvarim
she-nis-chadshu ba-galus. So those are two very different
things: minhag and mi-divrei sofrim. So which one
is it? It's a whole thing is very
very strange. So the Rambam does hold, and
this is how the maskana of the Gemara
in Beitzah is, that there's a difference between
the Yom Tov, of Rosh Hashanah and all
other Yamim Tovim. Rosh Hashanah is what we
call kdusha achas and yoma arichta, exactly. And
the Yom Tov a regular Yom Tov, is
shtei kdushos. That's what the Rambam writes in
halakha chof dalet here in Perek Aleph. So
what's a nafka mina? Potential? Well
I guess we'll get there, but what's a
nafka mina? I mean, Eretz Yisrael. What's a
nafka mina halakha l'maiseh? Beitzah. A beitzah shenolada
b'shabbos or be'yom tov. So a beitzah that's
laid on Yom Tov do we say it's
assur on the next day or not? If
it's Rosh Hashanah, it's a problem because any
time you have an egg that's laid that
day is assur. So if it's kdusha achas
like Rosh Hashanah, so I can't eat it
the next day because it's as if it
was laid that day. But if it's Yom
Tov sheni shel galuyos and it's shtei kdushos,
so then one of them is chol. Right?
So either the day you're eating it is
a weekday which isn't a problem, or the
day it was laid was a weekday which
isn't a problem. There's also in terms of
Eruvin that there're two or three nafka minas.
I was just trying to test the beitzah
guys. Don't you just have to wait because
it'll become muttar the next day anyways? No,
that would be a reason why there would
be no bitul. Right. davar sheyeish lo matirin,
which is what you're saying, that's something that
there's no bitul. Meaning it's if it's muttar,
it's muttar. I don't need bitul. Meaning, again.
You're saying it's muttar on one of those
days but you don't know which one. But
it doesn't no no, it's muttar for me
to eat on the second day all the
time because either it was laid on the
day that was chol or today is chol.
So it's automatically mima nafshach it's muttar. I
was trying to think of a phrase, thank
you. Yeah. But I think the answer is,
and I think Ari already pointed this out,
is that when you look in Kiddush HaChodesh,
the way he says it is really what
it is is it's a takana, takanas chachamim
hu she'yizahru b'minhag avoseichem she'beyadeichem. That what it
is is the way again the Gemara has
it is shalchu mitam, that the reason is
hizahru b'minhag avoseichem b'yadeichem. The way the Rambam
adds in is it's a takana that hizahru
b'minhag avoseichem. What that means is there was
a takanas chachamim that said the way that
your forefathers held of Yom Tov sheni, that's
what you should be doing. That's really what
the takana is. Now if that's true, well,
comes out something interesting, which is the other
thing that Ari said. If we think about
what happened in the time period of the
Beis Hamikdash, so if you were living in
America, did you have a minhag to keep
two days? No. It's not a minhag, it's
not de'oraisa, but it's midina, it's a safek.
A safek isn't a minhag. This is what
I have to do. There's no like, oh
this is part of my custom that I
keep two days. A minhag is something that
developed you know, the minhag developed gebrochs. So
there was a community that decided we don't
want to do this. This was a sfeika
de'dina. It was midina. The halakha was you
had to keep two days. No no, outside,
in America. Right? You had to keep two
days. So it wasn't a minhag then. So
it's a strange concept, hizahru b'minhag avoseichem b'yadeichem.
Exactly yes, yes I apologize. Right, they didn't
have the calendar so they it was a
real safek. I don't know if Pesach is
today or tomorrow. So it's not a minhag
to keep two days. I have to keep
two days because that's the only way I
can possibly keep Yom Tov, to avoid a
lav of an issur kares. Yeah. So so
so because of that, so that's really what
it is. So it's a funny thing, hizahru
b'minhag avoseichem b'yadeichem. Be careful with the minhag
of our forefathers. What minhag are we talking
about? So the answer, at least one way
to look at the answer, is that we
don't mean minhag in the sense of minhag
like gebrochs or minhag is to wear this
type of tallis. We don't mean a minhag
like that. We mean minhag in the translation,
the actions, the customs of your forefathers, what
they acted when they were in galus. hizahru,
keep those. Meaning what the takana is according
to the Rambam is to do what they
did as they did it. That's really what
the takana is in essence. So if that's
true doesn't the Gemara give a reason, right?
The Gemara right there with Geziras Hamalchus. Yeah.
That one day it must become we're not
going to be so clear, they burn our
books, we don't know what to do, we
don't know how to calculate anymore. So what
does that have to do with anything? Well
no, because now if you only if you
don't hold by what they did, their customs,
their practices of two days, you won't know
which day and then you'll No no, I
agree with you that that's why there was
a takana though. That's the point. Meaning the
takana was that we're afraid something may happen,
so do what they did. It's not just
keep the minhag alive, it's do what they
did. hizahru b'minhag avoseichem, that's why you have
to but that's the takana. That's the proof
of why it should be a takana and
not a minhag. Yeah, yeah, oh that's yes,
yes, yes. So really though in America it
makes their ancestors did two days. Yeah, but
once again, their ancestors and ancestors. Well, okay,
but I'm saying Ashkenazim, right, if they don't
have a reason why their ancestor did it
and now they're not in the place. No,
but yeah, shalchu matam is that when you're
in chutz la'aretz, you have to keep, do
chazaka k'minhag avoteichem. Once you move to Eretz
Yisrael, so that's the place where, where you
only need. I'm just saying but if it's
dependent on what your ancestors did, then you
came from a place that never kept one
day. But, but, meaning shalchu matam is that
they sent from Eretz Yisrael to the bnei
chutz la'aretz. So it was only talking to
people in chutz la'aretz. I get the idea.
I'm just saying like if you're coming from
your ancestors, we change what ancestors did. If
you move locations, you change what they did.
Yeah, but, but again, if you were living
in America. My point is it goes by
the location, not the, not what you did
before. Even if ancestors were living in chutz
la'aretz, if they went to Eretz Yisrael, they
only keep one day. Exactly. But, but that's
only meaning and then they would go back
and they would keep two days. But why
would they keep two days? They'd keep two
days because that's what their ancestors kept. They'd
keep one day because they're in Eretz Yisrael,
they don't need, they don't count. But if
this is true, if this is the way
to understand that what the takkanah is, the
takkanah is to do what they did. So
now, let's think of this. So A, it
wasn't a safek, it was, I mean it
was a safek, it wasn't a minhag, it
was a safek and they did what we
call midina. Now B, what, what happened if
you lived in America in the time of
the Beit HaMikdash? Second night of Shavuot comes.
Would you start early or... no, no, definitely
not. You can't. It's a sefeika d'yoma. So
when we say the concept of hizaharu b'minhag
avoteichem biyadeichem, that really means the takkanah is
to do what they did. So that means
do what they did and in the same
way in the second night of Shavuot they
couldn't start early because it could be... and
wouldn't it be for every Yom Tov Sheni?
For every, no, there's tosefes by Yom Tov
Shavuot doesn't have tosefet right? Shavuot is the
unique holiday that doesn't have tosefet, In this
case you can't because the second day could
be, could be the first day and then
you would have a problem of temimot, you'd
have a problem with whatever it is, but
you would have an issue. So that's what
even the second day. So that's perhaps that's
what the Knesset HaGedolah that we started with,
that's the logic. The logic, the reason to
say that even the second day of Shavuot
I shouldn't keep, I shouldn't start early, I
should wait to start late, is not because
the gezeirat hakatuv like we said. No, the
idea is no, really is a din in
temimot, but you need a full week. But
the idea of Yom Tov Sheni is a
takkanah to be hizahir b'minhag avoteinu and the
way that they kept Yom Tov Sheni and
the way that they kept Yom Tov Sheni
shel Shavuot obviously was not to start early
because it could have been the first day.
So perhaps that's where the Knesset HaGedolah. So
where does the Pri Megadim disagree and really
where we disagree? So presumably what he says
is that now, now that we are experts.
So what hizaharu b'minhag avoteichem biyadeinu according to
the Pri Megadim is just that what we
call the kedushat hayom has to be the
same, meaning that we keep a second day
of Yom Tov. But that means just like
they kept a second day of Yom Tov.
misafek, so we still keep a second day
because again we're worried that if something happens
we won't know, we're going to lose the
calendar, so we always just keep two days.
But it doesn't mean the way you keep
it is exactly the way they did it.
That's probably where the Pri Megadim is coming
from. But I thought it was just at
least an interesting way to understand the Knesset
HaGedolah. Yeah. When you said experts, it's a
fixed calendar. That's what I mean by experts.
That's what I mean. Experts, meaning the Gemara
says right bekiin b'kivya deyarcha that we're, I
mean we know the calendar until Eliyahu came.
Yeah, so that was, I thought that was
an interesting discussion between the Knesset HaGedolah and
the Pri Megadim and specifically to understand the
Knesset HaGedolah and understand what it means or
at least one way of understanding hizaharu b'minhag
avoteichem biyadeichem according to the Rambam that that's
the takkanah to do what they did. Just
maybe to conclude with a little bit of
I guess what we call divrei agaddah. I
remember a few years ago I heard the
following from Rav Eliyahu Brudny, who's the Rosh
Yeshiva in the Mir in Brooklyn. So he
had the following he'arah which I thought was
very interesting. The question that he posed was
why it is that we begin Shavuot, the
first thing we do is a chumra. The
first thing we do is this chumra not
to start Shavuot early. So we wait until
tzait hakochavim. Again, that's a minhag. That's the
minhag is to wait. But it's not midina.
You can start early if you really wanted
to. There's no din d'Oraisa. This was a
minhag that the Magen Avraham brings down, the
Taz brings down. But why do we start
it with a chumra? That was the question
he posed. So the way he answered it
was based on something that the Gaon writes
in the Gemara in Berachos on daf chof
amud bais. The Gemara says the following: Darash
Rav Avira, Rav Avira says, zimnin amar lah
mishmei d'Rabbi Ami, some say it was in
the name of Rabbi Ami, v'zimnin amar lah
mishmei d'Rabbi Assi, some say it was in
the name of Rabbi Assi. Amru malachei hashareit
lifnei HaKadosh Baruch Hu, the malachim said to
Hashem, Ribbono shel Olam, God, kasuv b'Torascha, it
says in your Torah, asher lo yisa fanim
v'lo yikach shochad, that you can't show favoritism,
you can't collect bribes. V'halo Atah nosei fanim
l'Yisrael, but you show favoritism to the Jewish
people, dichsiv as a pasuk says, yisa Hashem
panav eilecha, that Hashem will show favoritism to
you. Turn his face towards you. That was
what the Malachim asked. Hashem responded amar lahem:
V'chi lo esa fanim leYisrael? Can I not
show favoritism to them? she-katavti lahem ba-Torah I
wrote in the Torah ve'achalta vesavata uverachta et
Hashem Elokecha that they shall eat be satisfied
and make a bracha and thank me. Meaning
the Birkat Hamazon is when I'm satisfied. ve-hem
medakdekim al atzman and they were scrupulous on
themselves ad k'zayit ad k'beitzah that even a
kzayit and a kbeitza they're going to make
a bracha. So they're so scrupulous how can
I not be yisa panim? How can I
not turn my face towards them? So what
the Gemara what clearly emerges from the Gemara
is the way that we get favoritism from
Hashem is when we're noseh panim to him
as the Gra writes that if we're noseh
panim la-Torah Hashem is yisa panim to us.
What does noseh panim la-Torah mean? So noseh
panim la-Torah means this that even though the
Torah tells us strictly speaking satisfied make a
bracha achrona we're machmir and say no even
less we're going to ensure that we're going
to make a bracha achrona. But that's what
to be noseh panim means is a chumra.
The Gemara b'Shabbat daf yud gimmel the Gra
quotes talks about a talmid chacham that died
very early and the Gemara his wife was
complaining what exactly how could he have done
died so early he did all these amazing
things basically Eliyahu Hanavi comes and says that
he wasn't noseh panim ba-Torah. Whatever that means
on this person's level but there was a
certain chumra that he didn't do wasn't m'dina
but there was a chumra. There wasn't what
that's called noseh panim ba-Torah. That's what that
phrase means. And that's what again that's what
the Gaon says here that when we are
noseh panim la-Torah then Yisa Hashem panav elecha
veyasem lecha shalom and if not then Hashem
is not going to be noseh panim because
lo yisa panim velo yikach shochad. So anytime
we want that nesiat panim we want the
favoritism we have to show favoritism to Hashem
which means a chumra which means now for
each person that means something different right a
person has to see within themselves what chumra
makes sense to show Hakadosh Baruch Hu I'm
turning towards you I'm showing favoritism towards you
but that's the way that nesiat panim works
yeah. So giving up Tosefet Yom Tov is
a chumra? No we're not up to that
one second one second we're not up to
that. We ran very fast through that we're
getting there we're not so says it's not
giving up Tosefet Yom Tov is a chumra?
The chumra is that you're not allowed to
start before tzeit hakochavim which means giving up
tosefet. Yom Tov is a chumra why would
you do that? Some say yes and some
say no but the point that
he made is so when Klal Yisrael as
a whole are being machmir into a Yom
Tov of Matan Torah so the way that
we want to express our Kabbalat HaTorah that
Hashem is giving us the Torah is when
we're noseh panim ba-Torah as we're entering into
the Yom Tov so that Hakadosh Baruch Hu
can be noseh panim to us. But it's
specifically in the context of Matan
Torateinu on the day of Shavuot we begin
it with again what he refers to as
a chumra not to begin until tzeit hakochavim.
Or like coming in on a Thursday night
for a little extra learning avada avada that's
being noseh panim la-Torah and Hakadosh Baruch Hu
should be noseh panim aleinu.